ก็สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสีฟ้าคะวันนี้ที่เราจะอัด
วีดีโอนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
มีวันจันทร์วันอังคารนะฮะวันนี้วันอังคาร
เป็นวันองค์งานวันที่ 2 เป็นวันที่อัดนะ
คะเพราะว่าวันที่ลงยูทูปอาจจะไม่ใช่วัน
เดียวกันชายใส่แต่วันนี้วันอังคารนะคะมัน
ลงยูทูปวันไหนไม่ทราบนะคะอาจจะวัน
พฤหัสบดีนะคะโอเคค่ะวันนี้หรอครูเอกกับ
ผู้ฟ้ามาพบกันอีกในช่องอะไรครับกูป๊าต้อง
คม friend เซเบอร์ไทยค่ะค่ะคราวนี้เป็น
ครั้งอะไรคะระดับ
ค้าระดับต้น Dinner นะคะกินอะไรนะคะค่ะ
วันนี้ครูเอกและก็จะเล่นเกมกับครูฟ้านะคะ
เรามีเกมกันหรอคุย
เกมคู๋มีรูปสัตว์แต่งคลิปที่แล้วกอล์ฟมี
สัตว์ได้กลัว
อ่าคลิปนี้ไม่เอานะกลัวละแต่ว่าอ่ะอ่ะจะ
ให้ครูฟ้าคิดครูเอ๋มีรูปสัตว์อะไรจะคุ้ม
ฟ้ามีคำถามได้นะคะสีฟ้ามีคำถามและสิทธิ์
คำถามโอเคมั๊ยพอมั๊ยคำถามเลยหรอใช่แล้ว
ครูฟ้าก็ต้องคิดสัตว์อะไรอ่ากูฟังนะมีคำ
ถามได้ 10 คำถามถามว่าอันนี้มีขนไหม
ตัวใหญ่ตัวเล็กอ่ะมีมีขาใช่ไหมคะค่ะอยาก
อย่างศุกร์วุฒิว่าคลิปที่แล้วเราพูดกัน
เรื่อง
จะคุยหามาให้ดูก่อนดิก็ได้ค่ะผู้หญิงเสือ
เสือชนะเสียก็มีขาขาขานะ 1  2  3  4 ใช่
ไหมคะค่ะมีหารยาวมีขนนะมีเขี้ยวมีอีก
เขี้ยวอันเนี้ยเสืออ่าแต่ภาคเป็นเป็นอะไร
นะคะเป็นเป็นนกใช่ไหมคะน้องคู่ก็จะมีขา 2
ขา
อนิมิขนใช่มั้ยมีมีขนแล้วก็มีปีก
ปิติอะๆเนี้ยกูแฟร์ก็ถามได้นะคะคำถามได้
ถามได้ทั้งหมด 10 พอมั้ย
10 คำถามขอไปคะหรือจะเอาคู่เอกใจดีแม่
15 คำถามตายติดฮ่าคำถามขอให้ครูฟ้าถาม
การคู่คณะจักไม่เห็นนะคะว่าครูเอ๋น่ะมี
รูปสัตว์อะไรนะคะไม่เห็นอ้ะแต่ครูฟ้าถาม
ปูเอ๋บอกแล้วต้องเป็น yes-no  question
นะ know ๆอย่างเช่นครูพระถามตัวเองว่ามี
ขา 4 ขาใช่ไหมหมูเอกก็จะต่อใช่ไม่ใช่โอเค
มั๊ยได้ค่ะครูเอ๋ได้ค่ะแล้วก็นักเรียนก็
คิดไปกับครูฟ้าว่าว่าครูเอ๋มีรูปสัตว์
อะไรอุ๊ยเยอะเลย
โว้เยอะเลยใช่ไหมอันนี้ปลาหวานเมื่อวาน
ยังไม่เราครูเอกจะเอารูปอะไรไม่รู้ใช่ไหม
คะอ่ะกูอ่ะจะเอารูปเสือมาบ้างไหมทุกคนจะ
เห็นเป็นแค่เสือทุกคนจะเห็นเป็นเสืออย่าง
เดียวนะคะก็คือเด่นแค่เสือนะคะกูฟ้าเริ่ม
เลยนะอ่ามาเริ่มเลยได้ฮะรูปแรกนะคะรูปแรก
เข็มข้างหลังเป็นเสือนะคะแต่ขนาดในไฟล์
อ่ะกูมะขามและคำถามที่นั้นคำถามที่ 1 มี
อ่ามีขนไหม
คนมั้ย
มีค่ะมีขน
มีคนใช่มั้ยต้องเป็นคำถามพี่ฝนใช่ไหมจะ
ไม่แค่มีมีขนค่ะ
ฝนปั้นใช่ไหมคะขนสั้น
ขนใช่ค่ะใช่ๆขนสั้นค่าขนสั้นอามี
ขาเนื้อขา
สองขาใช่ไหมคะมีขาใช่ไหมคะอย่างเสือมีขา
หนึ่งสองสามสี่มีขา 2 ขาไม่ใช่ค่ะอ่ะ
ก็มีขา 4 ขาใช่ไหมคะมีขา 4 ขาใช่ค่ะกี่
รองเท้าและมีขนขนสั้นขา 4 คำถามแล้วตี 5
คำถามที่ดีมีหางนะคะ
หาหางนะคะ
หามีค่ะมีหาง
หางอา
หางยาวใช่ไหมคะมีหางช้างยาวยาวนะ
ยาว
หางยาวหรอตา
มี
ตัวใหญ่ใช่ไหมคะตัวใหญ่ไหม
ตัวอื้อถ้าแค่เปลี่ยนเกียร์คะเดี๋ยวเห็น
เดี๋ยวเห็นแล้วเปรียบเทียบกับตัวครูเอ๋
เอ๋ตัวครูฟ้าใหญ่ค่ะ
ใหญ่ๆถ้าเอามาเปรียบอ้อล่าสัตว์อันนี้
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าก็ใหญ่
ตัวใหญ่หรอ
อาร์มอาร์
[เพลง]
เอ่อ
ออกไหมคะหรือให้ถามต่อ
ฟ้าตอบได้ค่ะ
ซื้อเหลือ
เสือ
ไม่ใช่ซื้อเสือไม่ใส่เสื้อไม่เหลือ
อะไรนะคะม้าม้าหมาใช่ไหมม๊ามะมีขาดกูฟ้า
ขามมีขา 4 ขาใช่ค่ะ Mini ขนชัยมีคนเล็กๆ
สั้นๆวันๆใช้ค่ะมีมีอะไรนะมีขา 2 ขาวไม่
ใช่ VIP นี่หานี่หางมีหางหาชายมีหางยาว
ชายวิ่งเร็ว
ชัย
เสือไม่ใช่ครูฟ้ามาเปลี่ยนเป็นม้า
หน้าม้าใช่ค่ะเย้
หมาหมาเก่งมากเย้อ่านักเรียนต่อถูกมั้ย
นะคะอ่ะอ่ะ
อ่ะ
ต่อไปค่ะไปนะครูเอกก็ยังมีเสือนะเสือเสือ
อยู่ข้างหลังแบบไม่ใช่เสือนะคะไม่ใช่รูป
ต่อไปนะคะอ่ะกูฟ้าถามคำถามที่ 1 คำถามที่
อาจมีสี่ขาใช่ไหมคะมี
ขาจะมีขาสี่ค่ะใช่ค่ะมี 4 ขามีสีขาตัวสอง
ตัวเล็กใช่ไหมคะตัวนี้ตัวลิ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะสำหรับที่ 2 ตัวเล็กไม่ใช่ค่ะคำ
ถามที่ 3 ค่ะ
อาอาคำถามที่ 3 ตัวใหญ่ใช่ไหมคะตัวใหญ่
ถ้าเทียบกับครูฟ้า
ตัวใหญ่ตัวใหญ่ตัวใหญ่
คำถามที่ 23
44 มันก็ได้สิไหม
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
มีสุขผลให้คะมีขนค่ะมีผลถาม
ทั้งสองคนได้นะ
มีขนสีขาวใช่ฮะ
อ่า
มีๆสีขาว
ที่ 5 ใช่ไหมสีขาวหรอ
มีขนสีดำไหมคะสีดำใช่ไหมคะใช่มั้ยมีคนสี
ดำใช่ไหมคะอ้าใช่ค่ะมีขนสีขาวแล้วก็มีขน
สีดำอี
อาร์
กินคนไหม
กินคนไม่จิ้นค่ะไม่กินอ่ะ
6 แล้วเนาะอ่าสัมพันธ์ที่ 7 ค่ะอ่า
เวลาเดินเนี่ย
เดิน
4 ขาใช่ไหมคะปีขาสีขาเดิน 4 ขาแชร์ล้อ
ม้าลายค่ะหน้าม้าลาย
ใช่ครับเย้
ว่าลายม้าลายเรียนรู้ตั้งแต่มีสีขาวสีดำ
นะเอาหมีแพนด้าก็มีสีดำกินไม่ตาก็มีสีขาว
สีดำนะ
ไม่กินคนด้วยไม่กินคอนะคะม้าลายนะฮะแซด
ว่าจับปลา
อะไร
คุยได้แล้วโอเคปากคำที่ 1 ค่ะคำถามที่ 1
ตัวใหญ่ใช่ไหมคะใหญ่เท่าไหร่อ่ะ
เดี๋ยวค่อย
เข้ามามั้ย
ใหญ่กว่าหมา
ใหญ่กว่าม้า
ไม่ใช่
ตัวเท่ามานั่นแหละนักเรียน
คำถามที่พี่สองพี่สองเชิญค่ะอา
ขนยาวใช่ไหมคะ
โอเคไหมโอเคขนยาวไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่
คำถามที่ 3 ค่ะ
อะไรคะมีหางใช่ไหมคะมีค่ะมีหางหาจะมาหาง
มีค่ะ
[เพลง]
คำถามที่สี่
หาง
ค่ะอย่าเอา
คำถามที่ 4 ออกมีหูไว้คะมีวิว
อยู่ใช่ไหมแม่มีอย่าคิดเองขา
หมูที่รักแล้วนางสาว
คำถามให้
ถ้าอ่า
คำถามที่ 5 กินคนไหมคะไม่กินคนค่ะที่ 5
ไม่กินผ่อน
คำถามที่ 6 มีไหมคะเขาน่ะคะเขา
มีค่ามีเขา
คำถามที่ 7 เขาเนี่ยสั้นหรือยาวคะไม่มี
หรือ yes-no โฟร์ซันส์เหาเหายาวใช่ไหมคะ
เขายาว
ใช่เหรอ
ต้องฐานที่ 8
คำถามที่ 8
ผู้เขาตอบเลยหรอ
4mini เขานี้เยอะเลยนะนี่เขาเยอะเลยเหรอ
อ่อไม่ใช่ไหมที่ว่าสัตว์ที่มีเขาหญ้าเอา
ไม่เป็นไรกูมาตอบได้ลองเจ้าอะไรเค้า 7
กวางค่ะกว่าวาง
ใช่ไหมให้หนูเขาก่อน
ใช่มั้ย
ช่องกวางเอา
เก่งมาก
อยู่กับเขาตะคร้อใช่ไหมคะอันนี้ถาม
ได้ถามเกี่ยวกับสัตว์คอร์ดคนกินไหมก็ถาม
ได้ก็ชวนกินไหมมันเทศไทยมีไหมถามได้นะคะ
ว่ายน้ำได้ไหมมาถามได้นะคะ
ตัวจับไปกับหูฟ้า
โทรศัพท์ไปยังเป็นเสืออยู่เนี่ยมี
มีปีกไหมคะ
ปิ
มีค่ะมีปีกขอ
อะไรบิกสองขาใช่ไหมคะขา
มีขา
มีขาสองขาใช่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
ปากแหลมใช่ไหมคะปาก
แหลมแหลม
ใช่ค่ะปากแหลม
ตัวใหญ่ไหมคะ
ให้ไหมคะตัวใหญ่
ตัวใหญ่อ่าอะไรคะเทียบกับควางหรือเที่ยว
กลับมา
ขว้างกลับมาโตไม่เท่ากันแหละไม่เท่ากันนะ
มาใหญ่กว่าความวันที่กว่าๆกวางเหรอคะตัว
ใหญ่ใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่ค่ะตัวก็
ไม่ใหญ่
ตัวใหญ่ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
อ่า
ดุไหมดุใช่ไหมคะดุเรื่องแบบเสือคะอยู่กับ
เสือ
ดุดุ
ใช่ไหมคะ
คนเข้าใกล้ไม่ได้ดุดุ
ไม่ดุมากๆ
ไม่รู้นะไม่หยุดบินได้ไหมคะบินได้ใช่ไหม
คะบิลแบบไหนคะบินเก่งๆอินสูง
บินสูงๆ
กรุงเทพฯเชียงใหม่แล้ว
ไม่ได้บิน
บินได้ใช่มั้ยคำถามบินบินได้บินบินถ้าบิน
ได้บินได้ใช่ไหมคะกินได้ค่ะ v  r
เสาร์ 10  55 หรอก
มั่นใจว่าไม่ถึงเรามั่นใจเอามาถามอาอ่า
บินเก่งไหมคะใช่ไหมคะบินเก่งใช่ไหมคะไม่
ใช่
คน in ใช่ไหมคะคนกินไหม
กินไหมกินคนกิน
กูฟังขอตอบว่า
มากินไก่ใช่ไหมคะหรอไก่หรือเนื้ออ้าอา
ใช่ก็ได้
จุไหมไปดูไหมคะก็ไม่ดุนะแม่เราจับได้แต่
ว่าอาจจะเจ็บนิดหน่อยลองก็ถ้าเราคนไทยบอก
ไก่ไม่อยู่แต่ถ้าเสือดุนะคะเดี๋ยวดูขึ้น
น่ากลัวดุนะคะไก่ไม่อยู่นะคะก็เป็นไก่
เนาะอือแกะไก่ไก่ร้องยังไงไก่ขันไอ้
เสียงไข่
ไก่ตัวผู้นั้น
ถ้าไก่ตัวเมียกับพ่อตากับ
ไก่ล่ะจะไปหา
สัตว์ตัวต่อไปสัตว์ตัวต่อไป
ประเทศไทยมีไหมคะ
อยู่ในน้ำ
ใช่ไหมคะ
อยู่ในน้ำอยู่ในน้ำใช่ไหมคะ
แม่ไม่ใช่ว่ายน้ำใช่มั้ยอยู่ในน้ำอยู่ใน
น้ำอยู่ในน้ำ
ไม่ใช่อะไรอ่ะแต่ไม่อยู่ในน้ำไม่อยู่ใน
น้ำทั้งๆที่ 3
มีปีกใช่ไหมคะปีปีกไม่มีค่ะไม่มีปีกคำถาม
พี่ C แบบที่สี่ค่ะมี 4 ขาใช่ไหมคะมีขา
หนึ่งสองสามสี่มีสี่ขาใช่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
เขาถามที่ 5 ค่ะคำศัพท์ที่ 5 เช่นกันค่ะ
ชอบอยู่ตัวเดียวหรือว่าชอบอยู่แบบว่าหลาย
ๆตัวแป๊บ yes-no  question
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
โทษอยู่ตัวเดียวใช่คะตัวเดียวคืออยู่แค่
ตัวเดียวที่ 1 ตัวใช่มั้ย
ก็ไม่นะ
ที่อยู่อยู่ตัวเดียวโอเค
อาอยู่กับเพื่อนก็โอเคโอเค
อันนี้ 2 เป็น 6 แล้วนะ 6 คำถามแล้วนะเอา
ล่ะคะที่ 7 หาที่ 7
ตัวใหญ่ใช่ไหมคะเปิดมาขอเหมือนมาแล้วหรอ
ไม่ค่ะตัวไม่ใหญ่
คำถามที่แป้ง
คนคนคู๋ฟ้าใช้คนชอบใช่ไหมคะเก๋ชอบคนชอบ
ง้อ
ก็มีสีขนาด
ของ 39 ที่ 9
ฟ้าคนกินมั้ยกินใช่มั้ยฮะ
กินใช่มั้ยคะเอ่อ
ธรรมดาไม่กินไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่อุ๊ยไม่ใช่เหรอ
แถวที่ 15
เอาอ่า
เจอนานนะเออด่าน
เขาถามเสียงเสียงมีเสียง
ใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ฟ้าขอตอบมากป่าวว่าอะไรหมาใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ถามเนี่ยอุ้ยทำไมตอบมา
ก็ถามไม่เอากูออกไม่ใช่ไงเอาภาษากำลังคิด
ว่าคนเนี่ยชอบอะไรใช่ไหมมีหากกับแมว
หมาใช่ไหมคะคนชอบหมากูฟ้าชอบแมวหรือชอบ
หมาชอบแมวค่ะอ๋อแล้วชอบมาด้วยนะคะก็โอเค
ชอบมาด้วยอาจจะชอบหมามากกว่าเนาะอ่าโอเค
เอาอีกสัตว์อ่ะ
โอเคคุยได้แล้ว
อันนี้กูฟ้าอาจจะถามที่ทาย
ชนะ
เอกคิดกูอิสนะ
เชิญค่ะ
โอเคคำถามที่หนึ่งมีสี่ขาใช่ไหมคะมีขา
เนื้อเพลงสองสามสี่ขาใช่ค่ะคำถามที่ 2
ตัวเล็กใช่ไหมคะเล็กเท่าไหร่คะ Talk ไก่
มั้ยเล็กอาเล็กเข้ามาไหม
เข้าไหม
ถ้าพูดเดินหน้าไม่ใช่
เก็บเกี่ยวกับหมาอะไรอาเซเชียนหรือว่าหมา
หมาโกลเด้นวิธีเวอร์
โอเคใช่ๆ
อาคำถามพี่ 3 ค่ะ
ขน
ปั้นใช่ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
สักครั้งน่ะสั้นแบบแฟ้มแบบม้าเนี่ยไม่ใช่
คำถามที่ 4 หนกาวใช่ไหมคะยาวเท่าไหร่
ยาวบ่นตัวมี
คนแก้ว
ยาวประมาณไหนกูบ้านทับนิ้ว
อ่าก็ใช่ใช่
ถึงยาว
ค่อนถามที่ 5 ค่ะพลอินทร์ใช่ไหมคะคน
กินได้กินได้แต่คุณเอ๋ไม่กินนะกินได้
เดี๋ยวนะ
ว่าคิดอะไรอย่างนึงแต่ว่าไม่ใช่นะฮะค่ะ
ห้องถามที่ 6
อยู่ไหมคะเหมือนเจ้าอยู่หัวเสือดุดุใช่
มั้ยไม่ดุค่ะไม่ดุไม่รู้อ่ะแนะนำได้
ประเทศไทยมีไหมก็คำถามที่ 7 ประเทศไทยมี
ไหมคะมีใช่ไหมคะมีเดี่ยว
ธรรมดาไม่มี
คำถามที่ 8
เดินสองขาใช่ไหมคะไม่ได้ไม่ใช่กูฟ้าขาแมว
มีสี่ขาอ้าวบางทีนีศรีขาเดินสองขาต้องง้อ
เดินสองคราวใบสั่ง 60 ไม่ใช่สาย
คำถามที่ 9 แล้วคน
จะตอบได้เลยไหว
ที่ 9
ว่ายน้ำได้ไหมคะไม่ได้
ไม่เหงาไม่ได้ครูเอมไม่เคยเห็นว่ายน้ำ
ไม่เคยเห็นอันนี้ว่ายน้ำขอ
ให้ดูถามไปแล้วใช่มั้ยดุถามแล้วไม่ดุนะ
หยุดขนยาว 4 ขาเดินสองขาไม่ใช่ตัว
ตัวเข้าอะไรนะหมาโกลเด้นโกลเด้นอ่ะมีขน
ยาว
ประเทศไทยธรรมดาไม่มี
มีคนมีสี
สีขาวไหมคะสีขาวใช้ค่ะ
มีอีโอเอส
อะไรอะไรอะไรอ่ะยี่สิบร้อยใช่กูฟ้าเอก 523
นะนี่ห้ามถามหรอคำถามที่เอต
นี่หรอ
ถ้าวิ่งเร็วไหมคะใช่ไหมนี่เร็วใช่ถ้า
เทียบกับม้าใช่ไหมคะ
เทียบกับมาไม่ใช่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
ไม่ดุ
ตัวอะไรนะอะไรๆอะไรคนอะไร
ภาพสุดท้าย
มิสค้นค้นค้นค้นกูไปต้องคิดถึงขนลาไม่ใช่
ค่ะอ่ะ 11 แล้วเราไม่ใช่ปลาไม่ขนสั้นๆ
เหมือนม้าอันนี้ฝนมีขนขนสีขาวลาสีน้ำตาล
สีขาวตี 5
ไทยอบประเทศไทยไม่ตัว a  in
เดี๋ยวเอายืนไว้แล้ว 1 หมาจิ้งจอกหรออ่ะ
มีวิธีใช่หมาไปแล้ว
จะเสียง 2 แล้วนะเอาเอกยินก็ได้
นิวซีแลนด์
แนะ
แก่แก่
ลืมคิดเลย
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ประเทศไทยไม่มีนะแต่จะมีที่ว่าไปเป็นไป
ซื้อมาจากนิวซีแลนด์และมาอยู่ในฟาร์มนะคะ
เพราะว่าประเทศไทยร้อน
ร้อนแกะอยู่ประเทศไทยขนบ่ายๆฮ่าๆๆแกะชอบ
อะไรนะน้องหนาว Parts  Are  One นี้นัก
เรียนก็รู้จักสัตว์เพิ่มขึ้นเนาะจะใช่ฮ่า
ๆกับ 15 ซ้ำถามแต่ครูฟ้าเก่งมากตอบได้หมด
นะคะนักเรียนก็รู้จักอะไรคะกะยินดีค่ะไก่
อ่ะกูไปกินไหมค่ะกินไก่ค่ะกินไก่นะคะแล้ว
ก็อันนี้อะไรคะกวางค่ะกวางไม่กินเนาะไม่
กินไม่กินอ่ะแล้วก็อะไรคะม้าลายค่ะกินไหม
คะไม่กินค่ะไม่กินนะฮะอาจจะไปค่ะเมื่อกี้
เราถ่ายอันสุดท้ายคือแกะค่ะครูฟ้ากินแกะ
มั้ยไม่กินแกนกเอกก็ไม่กินแต่แต่บางคนกิน
เนาะอือน่ารักๆคือยังไม่กินจะไปอะไรคะ
ม้าค่ะม๊าม้าวิ่งเร็ว
ขายหารยาวนะคะอ่านยาวแล้วก็ร้องที่ไงค่ะ
พี่
Google ฟ้าอิอิมาเป็นมั้ยอยู่ข้างบนขี่
มาไม่เป็นไม่เสร็จเหรอ
ละก็ตัวสุดท้ายอีกตัวนึงก็คือหมาค่ะหมา
กินไหมอ่ะไม่กินหมาไม่กินหนออ่านะเราสอง
คนไม่กินนะคะน่ารักนะคะวันนี้นักเลงก็อ่า
เล่นเกมกับเราและตอบได้ไหมไม่รู้ถ้านัก
เรียนตอบได้
คอมเม้นให้เราด้วยนะคะว่าตอบได้ไหมว่า
สัตว์ที่ภูฟ้าถามครูเอ๋คืออะไรนะคะอ่ะวัน
นี้คุณเอกกับครูพาต้องไปต่อนะคะๆเลยอาจร
ไปกดแชร์กดไลค์กด Subscribe ด้วยนะคะใช่
ค่ะขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะน้ามายด์
[เพลง]